hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
lead I'm a property investor and you
know what I like to teach a ton of
people to also make a ton of money in
property I'm gonna be introducing you to
two people Samuel and Sophie they're a
couple they've got a family they've just
become financially free through property
after coming on some of our training
programs but I wanted you to hear
exactly how they did it and really
understand the mindset between people
that are successful and people that
aren't so you're gonna learn a lot from
this video if you've become financially
free from watching my videos often come
into my training programs then please do
finding that in the description below
winners on a Wednesday calm and you can
apply to all so we start here with me on
the YouTube channel so welcome Samuel
and Sophie we are so surprised at how
everything's gone in the last couple of
months it's been incredible yeah just
all all thanks to you tell us what deal
should be done because you're now
technically financially free respect
respect so how much money you make in a
month so about two thousand plus yes so
conservative mm yes I mean geez that's
incredible yeah exactly how much money
did you start with and we've actually
joint ventured with families so we
started with none of our own and we we
borrowed and gave we're giving good
returns so that's you start with nothing
so mother-in-law after selling our house
I think invest about forty forty yeah
and we always that recommend and the
service information fence around yes
they've done a nice combination yeah
yeah crazy yes
how did you guys meet how did you what
made you get into poverty what your
backgrounds and stuff
we were out one night family we have
similar friends yeah and we were both
yourself out having a good time
we were stood at the bar you were we
spent time together we worked out that
we had so much in common and then we
were solving SEP from there and then we
had our daughter she's now five and
we've just recently had our second or
our who's five months old as well yeah
thank you so what's the strongest what
would you strongest reason why for
getting into policy I think it's the
time element because yeah you don't you
don't realize how much time you have
before you have start family yeah and
then you're just trying to get that time
back so yeah so has been amazing at like
dealing with the children and dealing
with property at the same time yeah so
yeah you know I just we just want to
give our children as much opportunities
to experience life from the best
perspective they can and not just
education in school we have to take them
places and different things take them on
trips meet people and it's just opening
their eyes or something that's not
necessarily what they get taught in
school mmm should teach in school
yeah I agree possibly I mean there
all the teachers callers have to get a
job yeah so the training you how to get
job ye get good grades good
mortifications become become good at
complying when the bell wins you do this
when yeah and I think if you implement
that in them is such a young age they're
only going to grow and expand themselves
so you mean teach them what the way of
the free thing you know I'm actually
free yeah yeah so how did you even come
up with me on the crazy ludicrous idea
of into property becoming a property of
Japan how that happen so I am was
recovering after I broken my leg and I
was just sat in bed watching youtube
videos and one of my friends had
attended one of your courses previously
and it just popped into my head not to
start typing in Samuel leads their
property investor and then all of your
videos were popping up I just binge them
and I watched videos on like loud volume
so so overheard the videos in the
background he said oh here's this guy
you know welcome to my name is Tom
believes it so it was quite quite loud
to know I
she had then eventually came and watched
a few videos and that's how she got
involved we discussed we're wanting to
invest in property but I think before
you have the knowledge it's thinking
that's unachievable yeah and then I was
like why are you like why you're not
gonna be able to do anything from here
like we need to save money and then I
come on the course and we just had our
eyes open to so many yeah it's very much
work really hard save up money and I'm
just bagging this mantra you know work
really hard save up money put it in the
bank or put it into a property but if
you do that then pay off the more we
just quit
yeah and then if you're really fortunate
they'd have you in your forties or
fifties you might be able to have
another deposit save for an investment
property or a secondary which is so slow
you don't have to do that and you can
literally do what you guys did which is
actually we're not have any money but we
can do ready to rent or we can raise
money yeah yeah put it into a property
we didn't realize we were actually doing
an assisted sale and we lived in sorry
yeah so we were paying rent when the
baby came instead of moving out we paid
rent to mother-in-law and after like
five years paying rent we sold the house
and got back our deposit so it was at
that point we were like do we decide to
buy our own house or should we move back
in together and after watching so many
of your videos we just decided the best
room would be to go back together as a
family buy a house and ended up in being
in Wales
which had a huge amount of equity so we
just ended up using that equity to
invest and she's invested and now she's
getting the return that she's
financially free to my mum's on board
now as well yes she's now gonna become
financially off the back of what we've
learned from you so predominantly retail
and banking no no we've replaced my
salary with serviced accommodation
coming in yeah so I'm now probably not
gonna be going back to work after
maternity leave so nice yeah that's
correct
I think having kids as well yeah please
even if you go back to work the Father
you don't have to yeah it's just so nice
yeah and I can do my photography
freelance and then that means that I've
got more time to spend with them amazing
yeah did you enjoy your job before loved
it so that's really interesting you
loved your job but you still wanted to
become financially free yeah about that
choice and that independence yeah
because it's not always having to rely
on other people to control your time
it's being able to just be free and
travel the world and see things
otherwise you're restricted until your
pension age yes Ellen Rita yeah no I'm
not the opposite actually I actually
really enjoy what I do so I'm not as
inclined to leave it so soon yeah and
the team the team child to them the team
of a team are amazing yeah yeah so I
think having a job that you enjoy right
now you look at your job you probably
are gonna go back to it but you have the
choice yeah it's not and having the
choice if you do continue a job like
yeah you're probably work way better
yeah and you all probably your teammates
and your managers will be like Samuel
man this dude's good because you're
working from a position of abundance
rather than watching the clock thinking
I wish I wasn't here when they become
financially free
they'll just want to learn a beach
forever yeah actually no one wants to
learn of each other
no I think yeah I mean they might want
to learn a beach but then after two or
three weeks they'll be thinking how can
I know how can I leave the world better
than I found yeah I said to myself one
side you know God got my family in a bit
of good position I would look at myself
oh yeah
what we're doing right now that's great
yeah so talk to me then about these two
deals yes so you've nested in one hmm
yeah where you raise the phones yeah
you've got a renter Magnus so how much
you making on the renderman so in the
first 18 days he must have generated I
think about six thousand pound but with
you know all the fees and the bills paid
it's left so nearly like two grand so
yeah this is why she she doesn't have to
go back to work if she doesn't want to
the HMO itself which we got through
Alistair and that sauce is a five bed
mid terrorists in Spalding so that's
going to be generating very hundred
after also increase the rental yeah so
that's the next step for that one yeah
the service we managed to turn around in
the furnishings of it in 24-48 hours and
then we had someone stay after three
days the Spalding that Lincolnshire farm
Brown I think that's close to home his
parents home farm bro yeah so how much
okay so talk to me about the lessons
through getting the deals because I
always say your first deal is your
harvest yeah you've got a property deal
what you've managed to actually you've
also done one where you've controlled on
a regular basis yeah they're both cash
flowing very healthily between the
you maybe you'll be making a profit of
roughly three men on a bad month maybe
two - and which again is great so I want
to know the pitfalls the struggles the
pain by almost as if you were advising
yourself six months you're six months or
12 million go self yeah about how to
find the areas how to secure the deals I
just want to give as much value to them
to the listeners as possible so go
through told me through some of that
so pitfalls it's just finding the power
team that is you you if you don't have a
good partying that as a major pitfall
yeah but luckily we made some good
relationships with people on the way and
they've been really good at advising us
sort of step by step to creating
especially the serviced accommodation
making it exactly what we want to be and
pulling the most potential out of there
he actually lives locally to where that
site is as well so helped us source the
property and then it was quite helpful
of setting up the companies and getting
everything sorted ready to go yeah I
guess his I want to say it's been quite
smooth for us it's been quite smooth the
only of the only things are things that
I have been our sort of our control
with regards to like the sellers
solicitors and those types of things but
it's the process to be patient yeah
we've managed to control everything
within our control yes yeah that's great
I think as well when it comes to
property you've got to be really fast
when you have balls in your court
yeah but then really patient yeah
when a scenario because when when you
weigh in on solicitors or mortgage
brokers or publications or yeah or
planning permission sometimes things
just take time yeah and that's where
your impatience that's been our biggest
perform really what your patient has
killed you a little bit because we've
been seeing the success of others and
we've been thinking our man we've still
done very very well but it's just been
that comparison to me to others and but
then there's but then at the same time
yeah impatience will be your best friend
yes yeah
when you're thinking I need to get this
deal done fast and when the balls in
your court you look back yeah or a deal
will come you see this you guys are on
the economy you've been to the crash
course yeah yes July okay so most people
even when they get the best deal in the
world the carnival sign it yeah yeah
because it's just you know putting the
brakes on everything yeah but no trust
himself and brother confidence we do you
have because you have the knowledge yeah
because knowledge brings confidence you
know challenges smooth I mean if she
said the biggest pain point to be seen
other people we wanted to go in guns
blazing but we could we had a lot of you
know just moved in house babies calm and
you know we wanted to take take our time
but we've done well with the time that
we have six months financial freedom
yeah it's not the first three months you
sort of like throwing cards out there
and doing lots of viewing speaking to
lots of people and then you finally find
them deals that you're like yes they're
the ones go forward with it and you sort
of just put everything into it and
there's just a waiting game yeah I took
acceptable yeah it's 100 miles per hour
than it slows down as soon as talking
about the positive peer pressure within
your the economy new friendships you're
encouraged to network and like Matt I've
made so many friends it's been amazing
I just it's just the air there's just
just the environment it's just amazing
I've been to a few other events and it's
you they're just they just can't
compare them you just call comparative
so give me a few different yeah yeah so
if you're around people and you're in
the environment and friends yeah killing
the in poverty yeah you got five people
they were financially free and then your
best friends you'll be the sick yeah
you've got five people that all just
talk is you just bouncing off every
single one of them yeah you know I think
sometimes you talk to people about your
journey and what you've got planned in
your head and some people either really
get it or they just really don't yeah we
did up this conversation you know some
people are like yeah that's also a man
understand that you're wanting to push
forward and then other people were like
why why would you do that is so
uncertain it's so scary but if you don't
take that leap yeah I mean going from
teaching into property yeah it's a big
difference yeah massive but I think if
you put yourself out there and again
knowledge is power so you can teach
yourself anything as long as you put
your mind to it yes people being
negative or trying to hold you back yeah
our friends most of our friends get it
some of our friends don't and some of
our family members get it vice versa so
it's just hard to yeah yeah yeah
actually freezing result yes I see but
if they were reluctant with that that
kind of held back our journey I could
have held back theirs
yeah so I think it's just cogs turning
isn't there you can open in their mind
but you're always going to get some
negative you do not pay attention to it
so true I mean you can always they're
always you know some people that don't
support you you can never something to
do and I guess it's best to focus on
those that do
but it was enough I mean I believe the
mini so hold on just not one person in
the family all my friends have a little
more hold on can you not just make some
new friends
yeah yeah I'll just say it cuts off a
weak friendships but maybe just be
careful how much time you spend with
people that yes boy what you do it yeah
did you ever did you ever doubt yourself
did you have any other thought were the
last six months or 12 long it's been
since you came to the crash course and
decided you know our man this isn't
going to work or this is just a pipe
dream you have yeah you have those
thoughts you have you have that no voice
I've been sharing a lot online saying
about a little little voice that never
tells you good things it's always bad or
you know it's like why are you doing
this it's not gonna work or it costs too
much how you gonna afford it you know
just the little comments here and there
just froze you completely off your
momentum train and you're just like but
we've got each other to like got this
contract we've got make it work and then
yeah bookings start coming in you're
like oh thank gosh because it's actually
you know reassurance that you've done
the right thing and it's actually gonna
yeah yeah what so saying we only had two
days to turn the flat around before
someone was coming back night yeah and I
was like so if we can't do it we're
gonna get bad review if he comes and and
and she was like no we can do it I
promise the wrong time and actually rung
us tonight there wasn't set up at almost
like by the way I'm a my way down from
the Isle of Man I'm gonna be there in an
hour
and we could look to each other yeah we
had flat pack furniture friends Liz was
there and she was like I'm gonna go home
again internet plugged in and he was
sleeping there that night no I left a
good review
but do you think that's almost like that
what happens when you force yourself
yeah to do it yeah and you have
deadlines that you have to meet because
if you if you'd had a month to prepare
it would probably take me a month yeah
if you develop to prepare it could have
yeah yeah yeah some people ask questions
and your thermostat is falling all the
time give me past questions that are
actually not that problem they're
actually they're potential problem in a
year's time yeah so I'm gonna go over
that's crash course knocking anybody
imma get it but someone said you know oh
when you become a portfolio then Lord
and you have more than five houses the
mortgage think exchange yeah and then
comes different I know what kind of moan
about this I said hold on how many
properties do you currently have yeah no
Wow right okay that isn't your problem
yeah go get four houses yeah get a few
grand a month coming in yeah and then
we'll address it then because it's just
constantly thinking about things
actually you need to just focus on the
few net have the big picture of what you
want to achieve and then focus for the
next week you know it's everyone's gonna
have problems although it doesn't have
problems but but but you just gotta deal
with the Palmers ahead of you and when
you can swing your life in an hour
someone's coming that's that problem
right now that's what we're gonna fix
you if you thinking about all but in six
month time or in a year's time oh yeah
this is hundred percent true yeah we
just we I think we've gotten used to
them
I think the children's helped us I mean
it is always looking at how so we
thought we saw a limited company and
we're purchasing through that and I
think so we have to have some foresight
but I think if you deal with the bigger
problems right now they're gonna swamp
you so you doesn't have to keep little
goals sometimes those problems don't
even occur so it doesn't even happen
that time you can't just gone with it
what do you think could have been your
biggest downfall so you've succeeded and
you're gonna go on to see a lot more but
what do you think be the biggest threat
whether it may be is the little boys
yeah procrastination distractions I
don't know what's been that the thing
that you had to really work on the most
I think yeah I think is getting the
right people on board and pushing
yourself forward because like you've met
loads of new people and they're really
encouraged you in your journey and I
think if you hadn't had those yeah that
could have been your biggest downfall
because you hadn't met the right people
to push you in the right direction so I
guess it's yet yeah what you have around
you is my motivation and as well I think
that's mine just keep just keep going my
partner and my children and my family
those those things are what is it that
accident didn't you a couple of years
ago yeah that's what kicked me off the
boxer honest motorbike just use me break
from that I think having to go back to
work and even if you weren't ready you
sort of have to go back and pay the
bills I mean back in that scenario and I
think from the back of that it gives you
a bit more determination to you spread
your wings and experience more of life
yeah cuz it quite could've easily not
happened but yeah I just want to stay
motivated and whatever whatever it is
I'm doing and this has just given me so
much purpose long I just can't stop
the group in question pictures of a few
houses pictures of the keys and also
socially as well yeah you've made I can
see that so true
people are like cheering you on and you
comment in and really see that just even
Facebook with a bit to the DA yeah thank
you well network nobody yeah right
I feel amazing yeah it's good I said to
Sam like there's no when we've posted
things on our own Facebook or and you
haven't had this good reception and then
you post on your group and then there's
like this overwhelming support yeah and
it feels good to know that everyone
wishes you well yeah genuine like
support and genuine answers and they're
actually interested in your questions
and yeah and that's one of the reasons
selfishly why I want do this yeah yeah
cuz I make so many friends doing running
the training company yeah and teaching
people how to do some wealthy people or
they've been successful which they are
don't a great competition for me I'm
thinking actually I'm quite elaborate in
partners yeah friendships I'm a hope
either day yeah I don't admit what's the
point of having a lot of money if you're
gonna be lonely yeah yeah and then you
guys have experienced this at the event
yes you know the sense of community
we've got four dinners afterwards that
it brings just it's great yeah that's
very yeah I've made so many friends and
I've worked with some of them
piers and Jolene they're very babe
massively helped us get those deals yeah
but I don't know if I would have had the
confidence to reach out and speak to
them in person
how did you make sure convince all
attract your parents both to come on
board so is my mom we so we lived in a
house in Surrey was we did an extension
and it raised the money on that house
and what do you know what we don't want
to be spending all our money here
anymore I'm pumping it into that
property we decided to sell up and move
to Wales and off the back of that my mum
had a chunk of money that she wanted to
invest and she was also did you own the
house my mom did
so yeah okay you were doing the
extension yeah so we were paying rent
each month to pay for the extension
which she'd put on after we had our
first child and then from there she
decided that she wanted to retire she's
getting older now she was in a waiting
job which is quite heavy told on your
body
yeah and like health issues she just
wanted to slow down a little bit
and then we sort of went to her and she
was thinking about just doing by refurb
refinancing deals but we thought well if
we joint-venture then she can put less
of a deposit in you can get bigger
return and from there we started showing
that your staff went to the crash cause
she went to the cross course and then
she just felt I trust you I want you to
be financially free she wants to be
financially free and we just pitched in
together yeah
she wants to see you well I loves you
supports you but like a lot of people
and even you know kids you know 20s yeah
27:30
okay so young young people what they'll
do is they'll try and almost beg their
parents oh I need some money
how can you lend me some money yeah yeah
where is where and that sucks yeah it
was ever dear but you guys are like hey
we can do business together yeah yeah
which one be better for you and because
I've been trained
matchballs well actually hitter you
could make more money you know you can
make and then you become valuable yeah
instead of just being someone who's
desperate yeah we didn't know how it was
going to go but we watched enough online
to see that it could work yeah and we
just said we're just going to give it a
go yeah
and she did yeah we've joint venture on
the HMO and then we are gonna be joint
veteran on own another reservists
accommodation as well
what did he ditch what was the setup I
would look like so she's basically an
angel investor she's put in the cash
when she just gets a return through the
limited company and so actually you've
borrowed money from from her you're
giving her a great return on investment
she's happy yeah but you own the house
yeah which is really cool yeah what
about your money so she's seen
everything we've been doing and she's
she's just amazed and she's on board now
so I think next year maybe February
February April we're going to look at
refinance in her house yes pulling out
maybe over a hundred thousand ish and
then just try and do some good damage
with that yeah but because I now know
what I know
having learned from the DFB in the
Academy and I've got time I'll be able
to find those great deals so yeah my mum
my mum will be in the same position of
so it's a moment next year which is
great for residential property she's
gonna yeah come financially free and
then buy another property down in
Plymouth
because the way we're toys to just cover
another two hours and pay off a mortgage
yeah yeah what's the advantage to
someone who's about equity to actually
refinance and then reinvest rock because
because because they're in their mind
they've been thinking I'm gonna pay this
mortgage off and then suddenly oh okay
then what we do is gone now you just
refined that there you more we did why
you don't go yeah how does that fit with
people most people's thinking ah so my
mum gets it now because she was that way
inclined before but haven't shown her
the deals that are out there she knows
that the mortgage can be paid from the
profits of the properties so yeah she's
basically living rent-free or mortgage
free so which allows her to have more
flexibility you know you can do a lot of
things and you've got your time back
yeah also I feel like by putting the
money out of the property that gives her
free time and then she can use that
money to invest in other deals progress
her earnings and then potentially with
that house you can either sell it years
down the line or leave it and have it as
a family home or she can change into a
rental so it's always going to be was a
mine sent me for having expect happened
to explain this to them yeah but they're
they're well on board
people just want to be debt-free yeah
and actually wealthy people on death row
well financially for it and they used as
their best friend yeah to fund their
deals we watched the video I'm talking
about good versus bad yeah and a lot of
people just don't have a relationship
with that like they should it's just
Spencer and spend or you know bond by
the lot of liabilities but yeah you know
if you use that wisely then you can you
can 100% succeed what is the next year
so another refinance raised some more
funds yeah complete on HMO then get
another renter so try and squeeze in
sourcing in between yes yes what
everyone should be a deal sorcerer yeah
yeah if you're finding deals anyway yeah
and won't that your strategy yeah along
the way haven't we weren't in the
position to sell them so you're mine
yeah so we were literally yeah we found
probably a three or four and then it
wasn't till afterwards where we didn't
decided not to use those when a car I
don't want to be compliant cuz I don't
have to spend a thousand pounds or
whatever we do speaking from line yeah
but then for deals know what you did and
I don't want to do the economy because I
don't want to spend I don't listen you
gotta let money flow through you yeah
yeah because if you think like I just
don't want to invest in anything or
spend on anything yeah then yeah kind of
a life is that yeah it's not yeah you've
got to constantly be invested so now you
are compliant
we're in the process yeah almost
which means all I wouldn't seen you sell
some deals what will be the biggest
piece of advice you give someone
watching this video that is maybe doing
a job that they don't like or they do
not that they just want to know some
security but they're just really
going to get into property and they can
start from scratch just find the
motivation to get go everything takes
nothing it takes a bit a lot of energy
to get something going but once you've
started it starts to to find its way
yeah I think yeah and don't give up when
it feels like it's being slow yeah yeah
yeah consistent because most people say
to me you know does it really work well
obviously every week for someone start
here yes sharing their story it's
possible networks the question is will
you work yeah as I know because if you
work it works yeah
what's your experience been of the
Academy what would you say to people
that were on the fence about the Academy
or do the crash course network network
network network take a pen and paper
write as much as you can down and review
that information yeah yeah the crash
course was like a whole different ball
game for us I think it was the first
sort of like yeah doors opening and then
you go there and you meet everybody the
energy so insane if what's up dancing
and it was amazing we went all the way
to Birmingham yeah that one and if you
could for about a week after it's not
there slow down for you literally on
like this buzzy Claire I would like to
look in I think we went back to the
hotel window so it's like it's ultimate
boost of confidence and like enthusiasm
yeah and then from the Academy happens
you need to invest in yourself and no
matter what that is you need to get that
education why do you think that yourself
you just you you could make so many
mistakes if you just if you just don't
learn if you don't put the time into
yourself to learn property stuff Eva I
think you have to invest in your mind
for it to grow you say yeah yeah people
say if you think education is expensive
try ignorance yeah my guys
that's crying I mean up above other
mothers in Germany I'm sure you'll come
on a whole new level
thank you so much for watching I hope
you found a better fishel useful
inspiring enlightening please don't
forget to smash the like button also if
you watch the videos and you're not
subscribed please do subscribe and also
turn the notification bell on so you
never miss a video there's another video
that I really feel you should watch this
was with John and Becky John and Becky
became completely financially free and
they had a lot of hurdles to get through
and I think you're gonna really really
enjoy the interview if you enjoyed this
one you can check it out right here also
if you want to become financially free
we have a property investors crash
course it's two days and it's free on
the house you can come along right here
and of course don't forget to subscribe
over here too thank you you can do that
now why have you not subscribed